can Stargate find a new generation of
fans that younger audience to keep the
franchise going welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so last night I sat down with Young
Harris if you're a regular sidetracker
you'll know him from the guy with hair
that appears on our Sunday shows he has
his own channel he's doing his own thing
over in America but he's only like 23
years old and he is watching Stargate
for the first time in his life
he's such a lucky bunny he's got all
those great episodes that we love that
he's not seen yet
so jealous Andy's got really great hair
I hate that guy
but anyway I sat down with him and I
asked him how did he fall in love with
Stargate what is he looking forward to
in the future and what is he looking
forward to in the next iteration of
Stargate when it finally hits our
screens hopefully
here is the interview so young Harris
I think you actually came and dropped a
few comments on the Sidetrack Channel
first time because you started watching
Stargate didn't you I think I I found
your channel almost immediately after I
watched Stargate for the first time I
think I just finished re-watching avatar
The Last Airbender and then I watched
The Legend of Korra I think for the
first time which both fantastic shows
but while I was watching those I was
reading Timothy Hixson who is Hello
future me on YouTube he does a lot of
World building stuff he talks about how
he he digests and talks about how to
write particularly for books and things
like that but I like to translate it to
film and all that kind of stuff but I
was just finishing his book
on riding and World building
and then I watched Stargate the movie
for the first time
so did you go into Stargate
because you watched the movie then she
watched the movie first and then you
went into the series
yes I watched the movie first and then
I think I actually figured out that
there was a series because of your
channel because whenever I said I really
like this because I just finished
reading the World building book and that
was what I just watched I had watched an
hour and a half of World building done
right after I had just read a book on
World building which excited me you know
I was like okay well this is great let
me let me delve a little bit more what
else is there to Stargate I know there's
more to it so I've Googled it youtubed
it and then your channel popped up and
it was not the Stargate that I
recognized at all that I was getting so
I was like
there's a TV series and started sg1 from
there
I've actually introduced somebody to the
greatest TV show you know that actually
generally makes me like my heart warm
that my stupid little channel has
actually done good
it's done great introduce somebody to
this oh man that's fantastic when you
actually started watching the first
series then I mean because that is a
little bit dated
compared to I mean by the end of the
series it was I think it's as good as
anything on even being made today but
the first series is a little dated I'm
saying then and that didn't
change your appetite to watch the rest
it took me
I guess we're just out of the whole
Pandy and all that but
I I've watched the last season four and
season five and the second half of
season three within I think maybe four
month time period which isn't super
duper fast but it's kind of my watch it
as I eat lunch kind of thing it's kind
of like my lunch show a lot of the times
or I'll toss on an episode if I got a
free hour kind of deal
the first three or the first two and a
half Seasons took me two and a half
years to watch because it was slow I
loved every little bit of it mostly for
the world doing and all that I'm just a
sucker for for all that and I I love
history and kind of putting all that
together it's my favorite part of the
series
but there's so many other things that
have been coming out and like you know I
try to see anything and everything that
comes out for the most part and
it just kind of got put on the bottom of
the list so if if I if there was another
show that I wanted to watch while I was
eating lunch or wanted to watch while
something was going on I would watch
that first and then over time I kind of
I think the episode that brought me back
in oddly enough was you're not gonna
love this but the hippie episode when
they all go back in time which is not my
favorite episode but I after watching it
I was like okay I like the concepts here
I really don't necessarily like how this
one was executed
but I know they can do better let me
watch the next episode and after that
I've just been
railing them out I I love it it's it's
so well done the thing that got me to
actually start the series I guess after
figuring out about
the movie and then coming onto your
channel and all that and then and
looking uh into Stargate was the fact
that it was MacGyver
but back to I kind of roped around the
initial question of is it dated and that
was probably why it was set on my bottom
of my list is because it is dated those
first two seasons particularly I think
season three they they add more fun
stuff but
it's still dated just CGI wise but
not not in a unenjoyable way I grew up
on avatar The Last Airbender Legend of
Korra Star Wars the Clone Wars so all
those little animated shows but my my
parents are both 65 and I'm 23 so you
can kind of do the math there I was
watching their TV shows when I was
younger and I would watch Andy Griffith
Show eating breakfast all the time Mary
Tyler Moore married with Children
uh all kinds of stuff so it really
didn't feel too dated for me at all
which was nice I I enjoyed it uh it just
the dating itself though was what put it
on the bottom of my list for a little
bit it was just a very low budget for
initially I mean that was that was
expected they didn't expect it to go on
to be the phenomenon it was I mean they
did not give them any money until about
the third season to make the show and
that's even I even it's my favorite show
in history and I still look back in the
first series and I go oh this is a bit
which is why I asked a question really
I'm surprised coming to the show it
didn't put you off though it just
because you still fall in love the
characters don't you I think as well
um thing that they develop
for them being very archetypal
characters and they could be just
one-off easy peasy and that's almost
kind of what they are in Stargate the
movie I guess not sg1 but
I'm just just adding
Dr Samantha Carter into things and then
I guess you you keeping tilk and and I
guess finding tilk and keeping him
alongside the the whole crew it's that
immediate character development that you
know you're going to follow these
characters and
I guess another thing that I was really
excited about I haven't played God of
War or anything like that but my old
roommate from the first year in college
adored it and I sat there happy and high
all the time just watching them play
video games you know I couldn't complain
and Christopher Judge is the guy that
voices Kratos in those games and I love
his voice it's just it's amazing I mean
it's indeed one of the best voices that
oh I see you did that so you did that
don't forget guys if you are enjoying
the contents you can hit the join button
and become a fully fledged side Trekker
and really support the channel also if
you are new like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out I I
just think that's one of the reasons why
Stargate is this popular is this the
character development like you said
Richard Dean Anderson is is O'Neill two
Wells it's just and then they did such a
good job with that but that goes into
this question really goes how does this
sort of compare them to the shows that
you would have grown up watching because
I'm thinking like your generation I
think about my son is roughly your age a
little bit younger he grew up watching
YouTube you know he's like he didn't
really watched I remember I I with my
Lance now that I got um all the cartoon
channels for them when when we got Skye
and then I suddenly realized after six
months I was the only one watching it so
we got rid of them
um because they don't watch that
television they don't they don't watch
TV that way
um all TV now is 10 12 episodes you know
stargate's 22 24 episodes some of the
seasons
how does that compare to some of the
stuff that you did watch in because I
mean there's it's there's a lot more of
it
so mentally I was primed for it because
I had my CW phase I when Arrow came out
I was watching it as it I I watched I
think up until season six of the Flash
and at that point I mean they were
Supergirl there was Legends of Tomorrow
there was the flash there was Arrow I
couldn't do it anymore and the quality
of just nosedived uh which is another
sg1 reference because I just got to
season six episode two where they had
the nose dive or O'Neill's about to have
to nose dive and then shoots the
Stargate out into space which is great
Anubis is terrifying I'm ready for more
but
I I was I was mentally kind of primed
for that I liked the 22 episode
aspect of things because as someone who
wants to write in in film and TV that's
just an easy formula just to pick up on
and and the formula itself is like okay
this is what we're doing
um and and I guess avatar The Last
Airbender Legend of Korra all the
animated shows I grew up on kind of did
something similar and the other shows
that I would have watched at the time
would have been
Suite Life of Zach and Cody and iCarly
and those Nickelodeon and Disney shows
coming out whenever I was a kid and
those were great in their own rights but
I never came back to back week to week
to watch those I would just kind of
watch them as they came on TV
but I was a big YouTube kid as well so I
think the only thing that kept me from
delving straight into YouTube and not
really
just sticking to YouTube because I know
a lot of people my age had they they
can't talk like film like I do but the
reason I do is just because I love it so
much I I since I was I think in fourth
or fifth grade I I know I've known
exactly what I wanted to do in life and
most people aren't like that I'm lucky
in that regard but that's kind of kept
me gung-ho with film and TV and I watch
old stuff almost as much as I watch new
stuff maybe not right now because
there's so much new stuff coming out
but I I I try to be as well versed and
as well balanced as possible and yeah
that I think that helped that helped I
guess mindset wise going into it I think
your teen years though for for me I
think for my teen years when I was like
13 14 15 was sort of like
a bit of a golden age of sci-fi the Next
Generation
you know and there was loads and loads
of really good Sci-Fi on my Telly every
single day
um you know just like I I think you
potentially weren't I don't know if you
grew this but we're in a little bit of a
black hole sci-fi wise there wasn't a
lot of TV shows when you were 13 14 15.
I mean sci-fi wise back then was really
just Star Wars the Clone Wars I mean it
was I was such a big Star Wars guy and I
still am but at that point all the
animation was coming out and whenever
Clone Wars was done and
and all the Star Wars got bought out by
Disney I didn't realize it until I guess
Rebels was done but then four years
after I delve right back in and then was
happy because we got more Star Wars the
Clone Wars later on as well but I think
that really satisfied my my black hole
of sci-fi for my my younger years but
something I forgot about a minute ago
one of my favorite series growing up as
a kid that I think really rooted sci-fi
in me was Ben 10
to be fair
I I I was a terrible one for watching
cartoons with my children
um and they were like you know I don't
want to watch it I'm sure what's Benton
and um and I I actually I watched Ben 10
but um
I've rewatched it since I think I
rewatched it last year and the original
Ben 10 series
maybe it doesn't hold up it's not the
right word but it's still fun it is so
much fun and I did like when they went
into their teenage years because that's
the one that I kind of I think watched
first before I went back and watched the
original series
I think that kind of implanted like
conceptual kind of things in my in my
brain because a lot of that is
hit a watch different type of alien that
does different cool concept you know and
that is where I think that love for
conceptual sci-fi Grew From it which
starving is
it's generally never a good idea to go
back and watch the things you enjoyed
when you could I went back and watched
the original He-Man series and it ruined
my childhood I was like how did I watch
this rubbish
um but cartoons were different back then
though they couldn't afford to do you
know like 80 shots a second and they had
no computers to support it so it was
just like we'll just draw the mouth
moving and no nothing else moves on the
screen for like 30 seconds because we
can't afford it
um
I feel like that are still fun to watch
or Tom and Jerry's you know and stuff
like that because the only good not the
only good but uh
Mary Tyler Moore I could still watch Tom
and Jerry now are they all Bugs Bunnies
they don't do the woods Warner Brothers
once yeah let's get back Stargate though
is it okay we're coming to the series
somebody that's watching it for the
first time you know for me it's my
favorite Sci-Fi show ever and you've not
got for the you know you're getting into
the real meter at the moment with a new
this series and everything but can you
put your finger on sort of what you
think makes the show special why why are
people still talking about it now even
though they're not that screens for over
a decade so I mean
with Stargate the thing that got me
excited from watching the movie and made
me want to watch the show was the World
building and the thought behind the
writing I I like not only the thought
but probably the thought process that
went into the writing uh if
don't don't don't kill me Mr emmerich
but I think Stargate might be rolling
emerick's best film on a purely
writing standpoint maybe Independence
Day is more it's a better film and
there's a lot of other things and he's
done that our actual good films yada
yada
but I think Stargate had such a larger
scope than he probably even realized at
the time which allowed for a show to
come in and run 10 seasons
and then those that show had a spin-off
show for five another for two I believe
right so and that all came from one
movie which had to lay the groundwork
for all of that and I I read the book on
writing in World building right as I had
watched right before I'd watched that
movie and that just
it it fully it made me fully invested
just having that that mental I guess
note of okay let me let me enjoy and
learn the process of growing a world out
it feels so natural in the way they do
it as well that
I love it I I think the the thought
process behind the writing
and
just the way they decided to World build
from that in a very grounded and
realistic sense I I was a little bits of
Star Trek I've seen
feel like that could be a future version
of ourselves Star Wars feels like it
could have been a long time ago when a
galaxy far far away and still a long
time to come in a galaxy far far away or
probably one not too far off from our
own I think the two things of sci-fi oh
to bring it back into I I have never
been that much of a video gamer in my
life I'm very highly specific on like
what I play I used to love Pokemon and
stuff like that but after I kind of got
out of that phase I would only play your
Skyrim or your I still haven't played
Red Dead Redemption but that type of
games right up my alley like Far Cry and
Fallout things that like I have to fully
divest into a character and and learn
about a world in they have to do that
in-depth thing you don't want to just
play it you don't just jump around you
actually want a story and a I want it to
feel like a movie Just 40 40 hours
longer in a way and the thing that
really probably did sci-fi for me just
as much as Ben 10 and Star Wars growing
up was the Mass Effect series The Mass
Effect games and I think between
Stargate and Mass Effect those are the
two most realistic depictions of I think
how
possibly we will deal with aliens
whenever we get to to deal with larger
species more than just us because it
can't just be us out there unless we're
in a dark Forest but that's a whole
different topic yeah well I think any
alien species is just very probably very
very far away probably but but no I I
completely get your point by the ground
and I always say that was my favorite
thing about Star Trek and uh sorry that
was my favorite thing about Stargate is
that it is grounded and realistic we
said it in the video last week didn't we
did it it was always that Evolution as
well they did build Starships they did
go out into the ground but they did it
in a way that was just like yeah that's
this is what would happen maybe
and that's why I'm worried about the new
series of star Gates because we're so
Advanced I don't want to be Star Trek I
wanted to still be Stargate
so you you know bits about what's coming
up because you know you've talked on our
Channel and things you know a little bit
about Atlantis you know a little bit
from what you've seen so far of Stargate
what are the sort of things you are
looking forward to you said you're into
Anubis at the moment
are there other things come up they
think I hope this happens or I hope it
goes that way or technology wise yes
because like you said it's kind of the
perfect it's it's not an elevator
they're not shooting straight up to the
top it feels like an escalator that's
taking its time of doing so a steady
Pace it knows where it's going
I I just got I think I literally yeah
the last episode I watched was season
six episode two right after they blow up
started the Stargate three million miles
away from Earth through the hyperdrive
from the x-302 which they would not have
had
their turn glider glider turned
um spacecraft wouldn't have gotten flown
out and just shot out in the space with
Apophis and tilk and
Colonel O'Neill and all that good stuff
but I I technology wise I'd love just to
keep getting that little bit by bit and
really that's the only thing um
looking forward to I guess
I say that because I'm trying to keep an
open mind one of the other things that
got me onto
Stargate in general was the fact that I
knew that there were two other series
and I liked that just because I know
there's good World building at that
point because if you had a good enough
series to make one and you can expand it
to three and still have good ratings
first off I saw MacGyver the other guy I
saw Jason lamoa and then Ming now when I
was like okay one two three I'm happy I
got I gotta learn this I gotta get into
it and I'm still very excited for Jason
Momoa when I get to SGU I'll have Ming
now win and I'm sure other people are
saying it I won't get too excited about
that
just very much in the background and not
really in it they don't they don't
utilize a brilliant actress as much as
they could
she's actually especially in sci-fi oh
yeah God yeah
um Stargate Atlantis are you gonna
really love I think and and sg1 as well
they sg1 reinvented itself a couple of
times
so particularly in series nine and ten I
think you're gonna really enjoy it it's
still sg1 but you know um Richard Dean
Anderson actually basically like
semi-retires
and towards the end he wants to spend
more time with his daughter and things
so he's not in it as much but they bring
in Ben Browder
um who you will love from Farscape when
you get around to watching Farscape yeah
okay we get an injection of new
characters and a new villain and
everything and it reinvents itself but
in Atlantis yeah we get a whole new team
of
um have you have you met McKay yet
there's mccabean in any of the Stargates
you've seen yet
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
most definitely oh yeah
and what I just watched yeah he has a
main part in Stargate Atlantis and he is
the center of David heal is one of my
favorite actors and when we get Stargate
back I really hope they get a part for
him somewhere
um but yeah Rodney McKay's fantastic in
it but um Shepherds it's still got the
same fun
but they unfortunately sucked out of it
for SGU it's still got the same fun as
sg1
um like you said Jason Momo was
brilliant you you look at this now and
you watch his character in SG in
Atlantis and you go you know he's going
to be
the big actor that he turns out to be
you know you just know I I'm watching
that show going this guy is going to be
huge you know he's going to be a big
action star and you know it's just it's
just fantastic but also Joe Flanagan
who's who's a character in this um who
sorry plays um Colonel Shepard again
it's just a really lovable actor and
he's just these characters that you just
fall in love with all over again that's
what I'm looking forward to the most I'm
keeping an open mind which I'm typically
good about
and I I'd say the characters and the
technology that's what I'm looking
forward to the the conceptual stuff in
the character development
yeah and then that's what you've got to
look forward to you lucky bunny I am so
jealous of you that you get to Russia
for the first time
but I I believe it is a
it's a John Hopkins study I believe but
I cited all the time
anticipation is more rewarding for the
human brain than surprise ever is so
it's just as fun to hear these spoilers
and then to try to just mentally
theorize how that's going to happen
where is this going to go I know these
characters are here and they're part of
the story that I'm at now
I know they have this much to get to
before they get to that point how is
that going to happen and I'm just
reeling in it for however long it takes
me to get to those points and I love
that that makes me so happy I do keep
trying on live shows when we talk about
these things not to ruin it for you not
to tell you too much but you've got so
much to look forward to oh just the
little parts that y'all do though it's
just so enticing y'all mentioned Anubis
beforehand like right as I was kind of
getting into season five and I was like
oh [ __ ] here we go here we go and now
I'm now I'm in the thick of it he just
tried to blow up Earth and I know that's
not the only way that he's gonna be
going at it so oh yeah the kitchen is
tickly with these things just to keep
you involved um you've got you've got
some really amazing stuff look forward
to so
obviously you know from talking on my
channel I talk a lot about hopefully a
new series one of your hopes for a new
series or what do you
do you have any I'm sorry I haven't got
through the whole series yet so you're
not as invested maybe as I am and I've
had 10 years to think about this but um
I'm quite nervous about Stargate
returning and particularly the way they
make certain TV shows at the moment so
do you have any hopes or fears about
potentially Stargate coming back
yes
yes
definitely and one of the things that
I love so much about it once again it's
my favorite word I'll keep bringing back
into the into fold but World building
if the show that this reminds that just
the way this is built reminds me of the
most is Star Wars the Clone Wars just
because
it takes something that we already know
expands upon it and leaves Avenues open
for so many other different things and
they're not necessarily written entirely
similarly I guess in certain ways
because it's fun campy sci-fi that can
be kind of washed at any ages but
there's some very serious things going
on and there's some very uh grounded and
and well well thought out
bad things going on in the universe that
all of our characters will have to deal
with so with all that just being
the beginning of six seasons in and a TV
show I mean and a movie
and I know that there's three and a half
four more seasons of just this one show
five seasons of another two seasons of
another plus the whole comic book that
they've finished up SGU with kind of
like they did I know with firefly and
serenity and all that you got a couple
of TV movies as well
you can continue
I uh I did watch Stargate Catherine at a
certain point oh yeah and that was awful
yeah but that was that was like a little
web series or something and it was like
you know it was supposed to be a prequel
it's sort of like thing but
I I knew it was a bit of ahead of his
time there it was they did that a bit
too
they're trying to do an internet-based
series
when streaming haven't quite got going
yet so I think they're a little bit too
ahead of their time on that one and they
never had the budget for it so it was
just not very good but uh yeah there
were two head of the time that would
have been just before AMC and Walking
Dead it would have started putting out
their webisodes as well which I think
that was right as that kind of hit-off
kind of deal
that wasn't my favorite but it added
enough to the lore where it made me
think a little bit
um it didn't take away from everything
else that I'd already seen but with all
that being said
I'm still I have over half of start date
left to watch in a lot of ways
what do you what's your hope that when a
new series does come
do not reboot it I I do not want a fresh
start I want to continue with these
characters there's way too much time
just
it if I've already invested this much
time 20 25 years after the original
series came in
I I that would just my heart would sink
like the second they would be we're
gonna start a new we're gonna do avatar
The Last Airbender but live action on
Netflix why
I mean it could be good but also
there's already such a rich source
material to Garner from expand there's
there's no reason to reboot it just for
the sake of a new generation
keep keep that old old guard there and
let that Old Guard bring in the new
guard
I don't know I would be very upset if we
got a full reboot and we did not just
get a a continuation of some variation
of the story because I'm I'm not halfway
through the story yet so I don't know
where I could pick up
but once again my brain just theorizes
in these different things and every one
of those options excites me I know you
talk about the furlings which if I get
some evil version of Ewoks I'll be
ecstatic
I don't know if they're completely gone
or what but that storyline I'm excited
to see that's creepy enough I just saw
the original uh AI that they found that
made the replicators and they give her
body to the Asgard that's interesting
and itself I I mean there's so many
different ways that they could take this
obviously we talked about SGC and came
up with that kind of little idea
[Music]
um
if they if they need a good show that's
campy but also with a formula that they
can base off of SGC will be perfect
that's the only kind of
thought that I really would have to give
them to be like this would be the show I
won because I just I haven't seen enough
to really say something yet and that's
just where my brain would go to be
generally
where could they
have have their cake and eat it too you
know
I am completely running with your SGC
idea and um I've gone with I've I've
basically now sketched out six series
based on this SGC series you came up
with so I've got um how did the dragon
in a way where they keep time hopping
all these different things each time hop
could be its own prequel series
every I mean I I don't know why they
wouldn't do that with how popular each
little set of characters had already
been
SGC could do the same thing just not
time hopping and just tossing in there's
give us some toll and stuff give us some
tokra stuff give us oh yeah the tolling
are going to be
I've got the first season not so let's
get to that now for the first season
um we see that the toll and refugees the
people that the Tomlin are left are sort
of like
um we have a an alliance with them and
there's a whole the first season is
based around the SGC but a mysterious
character just come through the gate and
he's very interested but we use that
character and we find out he is a
furling and but I won't go into too much
detail then the second series was
um Atlantis that I did a video on and we
see the Atlantis and the feelings to try
to capture it and they're trying to
rebuild that thing there we see the SGU
they say velai then the fourth season is
flashback to the Ancients and we find
out why the furlings are now
a protagonist
fifth season is going to be bored a new
BC 306 and then the sixth season will
actually be the culmination of that
whole thing where we actually have an
open conflict with the furlings and that
is my sixth Seasons six seasons and I've
sketched out already I mean that sounds
amazing though that sounds like
everything
I can imagine from someone who hasn't
seen all that could want and that sounds
like something that people that have
said it would be like as well this thing
the more I think about the more excited
I get about it and I'm like if I don't
make this show whatever they do make I'm
going to be disappointed by because it
won't be my sgcl your SGC show now we're
excited to Sidetrack SGC damn right oh
yeah um I'm just yeah so I'm really
enjoying thinking about that as well and
just you know and it's just completely
fan fiction and completely out of my
brain but um yeah it's fun to think
about but yeah
I don't see other many different ways
where they could take a new show I guess
just from where I I can guess where they
leave off on SGU just knowing that
there's a spaceship floating off in The
Ether in a way
it doesn't necessarily feel like the
easiest thing to pick up off of
but they've laid downward to do so in
the do so well I think
yeah there's so many ways that we can go
with the show that if I plan to if
Amazon decide not to do it which is
still a big risk which is why we have we
want Stargate hashtag that we keep going
for on Twitter
um
but there's for me there's no way Amazon
aren't going to do a new series of
Stargate it keeps trending on Twitter
it's trending TV and movies again at the
moment number one
um more and more on YouTube as well you
talked about podcast earlier in the uh
in the episode or in our live stream and
the podcast guy is going oh we know your
channel we watch your channel because I
know you do you've referenced it more
than once
you little Tinkers I've seen a couple of
their videos but the one that I see all
the time is nerd cookies videos she has
a bunch of videos that comes out she has
a bunch of good stuff that was I guess
we didn't talk about but we uh put it on
the side track stuff on the our Facebook
group was the uh
Dean Dean Devlin and Jonathan glaster
are making the arc which sounds like an
interesting show in itself but yes I
think that would be nice to show
please go and find M cubed there is a
link in the description it's a great
Channel Harris does loads of Bloom
videos he's going to be doing a lot more
videos on our Channel as well looking at
Classic Movies and new movies and asking
the questions did you buy a ticket or
should you skip it look out for those if
you're on into the Channel please
if you're on YouTube Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
really helps us out and if you enjoy the
content don't forget please hit that
join button
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]